this is what i've questioned the latest
news conference i've ever had
[Applause]
i appreciate it very much i want to
thank the american people for their
tremendous support
millions and millions of people voted
for us tonight
and a very sad group of people
is trying to disenfranchise that group
of people
and we won't stand
i want to for the first lady my entire
family
and vice president pence mrs pence
for being with us
and we were getting ready for a big
celebration
we were winning everything and all of a
sudden it was just
called off the results tonight have been
phenomenal and we are getting ready i
mean literally we were just
all set to get outside and
just celebrate something that was so
beautiful so good
such a vote such a success the citizens
of this country have come
out in record numbers this is a record
there's never been anything like it
to support our incredible movement we
won states that we weren't expected to
win florida we didn't win it
we won it by a lot
everyone the great state of ohio
we won texas
we won texas by 700 000 votes and they
don't even
include it in the tabulations
it's also clear that we have one georgia
we're up by 2.5
or 117 000 votes with
only 7 left they're never going to catch
us they can't catch us
likewise we've clearly won north
carolina
we're up 1.4
we're 77 000 votes with only
approximately 5 left i can't
but certainly there were a lot of votes
out there
that we could get because we're now just
coming into what they call trump
territory i don't know what you call it
but these were friendly
voters and that could be overturned the
gentleman that called it i watched
tonight
he said well we think it's fairly
unlikely that he could catch well fairly
unlikely
and we don't even need it we don't need
that that was just
the state that we would have gotten it
would have been nice arizona
but there's a possibility maybe even a
good possibility in fact
since i saw that originally it's been
changed and the numbers have
substantially come down
just in a small amount of votes so
we want that obviously to stay in play
but most importantly we're winning
pennsylvania by a tremendous
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're up 600 think of us think of us
we're up 690 000
votes in pennsylvania
these aren't even close it's not like oh
it's close
with 64 of the
vote in it's going to be almost
impossible to catch and we're coming
into
good pennsylvania areas where they
happen to like
your president
so we'll probably explain that
we're winning michigan but i'll tell you
i looked at the numbers i said oh
i looked i said wow that's a lot
weird almost 300 000 votes
and 65 of the voters
[Applause]
and we're winning wisconsin we don't
need all of them
we need because when you add texas in
which wasn't added
i spoke with the really wonderful
governor of texas just a little while
ago and greg abbott he said
congratulations he called me to
congratulate me on winning texas i mean
we won texas i don't think they finished
quite the tabulation but there's no way
and it was almost complete but he
congratulated me
and he said by the way what's going on
i've never seen anything like this
can i tell you what nobody has so we won
by 107 000 votes with 81
of them that's michigan so when you take
those three states in particular and you
take all of the others i mean we have
we have so many we had such a big night
you just take a look at all of these
states that we've won tonight
and then you take a look at the kind of
margins that we've won by
and all of a sudden it's not like we're
up 12 votes and we have
60 percent left we won states and all of
a sudden
i said what happened to the election
it's off
and we have all these announcers saying
what happened and then they said oh
because you know what happened
they knew they couldn't win so they said
let's go to court and did i predict this
newt did i say this i've been saying
this from the day i heard
they were going to send out tens of
millions of pounds they said
exactly because either they were going
to win
or if they didn't win they'll take us to
court
so florida was a tremendous victory
377
texas as we said ohio
did this ohio a tremendous state a big
state i love ohio we won by 8.1
465
almost 500 000 north carolina big
victory with north carolina
and so we won there we lead by
76 000 votes with almost nothing left
and all of a sudden everything just
stopped
this is a fraud on the american public
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this
so our goal now is to ensure the
integrity
for the good of this nation this is a
very big moment
this is a major fraud in our nation
we want the law to be used in a proper
manner
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
we want all voting to stop
we don't want them to find any ballots
at
four o'clock in the morning and add them
to the list okay
it's it's a very sad it's a very sad
moment to me this is a very sad moment
and
we will win this and as far as i'm
concerned we already have it
so i just want to thank her and
i want to thank all of our support i
want to thank all
of the people that worked with us and
mr vice president say a few words
[Applause]
thank you mr president i want to join
you in thanking more than 60 million
americans
who have already cast their vote for
four more years for president donald
trump
while the votes continue to be counted
we're going to remain vigilant
as the president said the right to vote
has been at the center of our democracy
[Applause]
i think
[Music]
you